a doctor says Indiana's largest Hospital
engaged in dangerous practices and put
pregnant women at risk when dr. Judy
Robinson worked as a medical director at
IU Health Methodist Hospital she says
she discovered lower paid midwives were
in charge of overseeing high-risk
pregnancies she says they did not have
proper physician supervision leaving
some patients with what she called quote
substandard care Alex Ferreira a judge
former police officer and host of the
CBS series whistleblower spoke to Polk
to her about what she says was an act of
dangerous insurance fraud dr. Judy
Robinson has brought some 3,000 babies
into the world in a career spanning over
30 years I got to participate the most
important day of a person's lives birth
of their baby when I was in private
practice I delivered people's second and
third babies but dr. Robinson felt
unfulfilled in her suburban private
practice she wanted to do more for those
with less so she took a position at
health net clinics been affiliated with
Methodist Hospital which catered to
low-income disadvantaged women I feel
like oh I'm making a difference
typically the patients I always see were
very high-risk they had multiple medical
problems associated with their care dr.
Robinson had been looking forward to
working with a team that included a
well-respected group of midwives a
typical role of a midwife in my mind can
be a tremendous asset to any practice
because he or she can practice
obstetrics in a low-risk normal patient
population in Indiana Medicaid rules say
midwives can take care of normal
pregnancies but the rules also say there
should be physician involvement when a
pregnancy becomes high-risk so you
absolutely need to have a physician
backup no matter what but doctor
Robinson says that's not what was
happening at HealthNet methodist
hospital a practice she says had fatal
consequences for this young mother
tane Tyler had medical problems that
were concerned
I risk it's a struggle every day every
day that I wake up and know that my
daughter's not here if they had listened
if they had brought physicians and I
can't help but think that today would be
here today a result according to dr.
Robinson of the tensions at health net
clinics between midwives and ob/gyn
physicians it was a midwife practice and
we were not to intervene in the
patient's care unless we were asked a
point that was forcefully made to dr.
Robinson by the head Midwife she put her
finger right in my face
and she said this is a midwife practice
don't you physicians dare try to take
care of these patients the only time
that you're gonna see a patient is if I
tell you you're gonna see a patient
people were being harmed and it needed
to stop now in a statement the
whistleblower I you health Methodist
Hospital and Health Net both deny any
wrongdoing Alex Ferreira joins us Alex
good morning what's one innovation
behind putting patients in front of
midwives in the first place well in this
situation like in most of our
whistleblower cases financial I mean all
our cases really are about corporate
greed and if you have midwives who are
being paid considerably less than
doctors and doctors who are being
reimbursed at a much higher rate by
Medicaid you have a situation where
midwives were being used to treat
high-risk patients which they're not
supposed to be in care of the doctors
are supposed to be in care of them but
the doctors were being billed to
Medicaid as if they were handling the
patients when they had little or no
involvement so you had some tragic
circumstances today Tyler's one example
of that what happened what happened to
her baby well it's what happened to both
of them actually unfortunately this her
case was every parent's nightmare tane
went through labor her mother was told
baby and mother are fine you'll be able
to see them soon and the next thing you
know tane died and her baby was born
with cerebral palsy it's believed that
it was as a result of substandard
medical care and they she is one example
dr. Robinson documented many examples of
what midwives were involved in where
they she believes they should not have
been hard to watch but important subject
elsewhere thank you very much you can
watch whistleblower doctors versus
midwives
delivery's tonight at 8:00 7:00 central
right here on CBS